I'm handicapped tournament here we go
whoo
ten seconds until kickoff 64 players
1895 average rating time handicap to 30
minutes bullet chess this is the war
zone Kings experience level 30 required
chess Cube any second it could begin any
second the first game that I played in
the last tournament it did not kick off
so smoothly will it be different
am I the only one no no no I'm not the
only one dark be dark be can I throw
this pawn right down and establish a
thorn I'm looking to establish a thorn
ok let's go with this I'm looking to
trap that Bishop I think I'm getting
ready to somehow with the pawn push next
I think I have that and I could actually
recapture with my queen initially I was
gonna take like this on the Queen I'm
gonna clean and now I want to get on
these light squares you can't castle now
pressure on that night I'm looking at
Queen side they resigned back to
tournament 2 2 2 a lot of time left
ok that age pawn you have to be very
careful about letting it get to that age
3 square very cramping long term
possibilities long term very good
possibilities do not do not
do not play the Scandinavian do not play
the Scandinavian opening okay let's see
now the Scandinavian is good
Scandinavian is good I should probably
leave a Scandinavian I'm working myself
into a pin but uh that shouldn't be too
bad I could slam the door in there
bishop have a nice little pond chain I
should probably think about getting out
of this pin very soon now I'm on the
bishop I could have maybe taken this
pond I'm opening up this file but did my
rook is a maniac now he's a maniac to be
careful with my pond nose but now
everything is being hid and I don't want
to take pin pieces I want to attack them
I'm gonna attack this Knight again or I
could just consider attacking the piece
that is defending the knight now
everything is going to fall now I
believe everything will fall let's get
this pond pushing this file is open up
the B file the Queen is hit check matin
- one - that's came back - Terman six
three sixes plenty of time Ryan Reynolds
Ryan Reynolds is on the scene
I was thinking foresight they're moving
so oh hang up on the bishop in the pond
and maybe the rook one day they ship the
pond and maybe they were up one day
that's how they were gonna that's how
they were gonna block if I capture there
Oh watch out get that clean out of there
get that clean out of there
oh no I drop my queen they drop their
queen what that happened it was Queen
takes Queen oh man
freak queens for everybody it's it that
rook
let's hit the rookie oh my goodness - is
that a free queen if I've ever seen one
okay kill this bishop push the pawn and
then look for maid on the back rank here
no matter what okay here no matter what
no not so fast let's do this
defend the pawn there is no backing
stuff they resigned back to tournament
12 sorry I got a bit too loud right
there that's why I sometimes will say
don't listen with headphones you might
just need to take it a step further and
just not listen at all
without you button get that new button
Queen d2 some certain certain moves just
they just do that they just do that to
me oh oh I have the square covered I can
still follow through g4 okay let's still
go with it Knight f5 looks very
appealing I have this covered these
Knights are within checking distance
then checking distance there and let's
just keep rumbling here keep rumbling
okay now this file has opened up I'm on
this bishop twice there light-square
bishop is well actually this is
threatening to just win the farm I think
starting to win the farm oh this is very
dangerous this is just TKO time
alright let's go in this direction and
let's make sure that there is nothing
tricky and by tricky I mean no tricks
against b2 let's come here to defend
although I'm not here oh man
little scary a little scarier than I
would have liked it to be a little too
scary still up a piece but it's now a
bit more tricky I don't know
12 seconds that's the other that's my
other fear oh I don't have any fear now
I have no fear right now right because
the Queen's are off and I can move a
little bit faster now I'm gonna play
faster the king is gonna get active now
my rook is there what's the time
situation on push for takes I'm on this
where are you gonna go right here I'm
looking for the rooks to now come off
rooks are off I just have to make sure I
move quick because close to being
trapped just come over here and I'm just
going to sack even if it's wrong I'm
going to do it back to tournament there
down on time 20 20 Oh 20 2017 do not
again do not let's try a different
variation here okay
tempo on the Queen they forgot it they
went with the wrong order I think they
were thinking a bishop here first and
then and then that move but now they're
without their lady uh what a bug
ah man I shouldn't have allowed this to
happen hmm
that night is so scary oh my goodness
okay let me give check first okay I'm
gonna lose my clean butt okay maybe not
maybe not now maybe not now I'm gonna
take that that's winning everything the
night and then this night all right
they're going to resign yes they did
thirty twenty twenty twenty tight pack
up there still a lot of time 22 22
minutes no I'm not so sure I want to do
that okay have a nice Center I'm gonna
look to have this battery eliminate
their dark square Bishop maybe instead
let me get my night on g3 so there's no
night h5 stuff and then I could get h4
h5 to be careful about development my
opponent opens up the position like
they're doing with c6 there could be
play quickly on the Queen side and now
with that well I still want to get some
development development in a navy Castle
queenside actually okay I'm not gonna
keep repeating but I could do this but
my rook up actually let me do that this
is a bit too scary for me actually look
at the play that there is there's a bit
too much play get rid of this Knight and
then this there is pawn push he's pinned
but okay I want to probably get out of
this pin with my king and then the
bishop is trapped since the rook is
still on f5 hang on though
hang on for a second okay now the bishop
could retreat I'm okay with no let me
give me a pawn going you just get this
pawn going okay still I want to break
this down he's the block hater so let's
remove him
and keep going can't be stopped okay
another rook is having to babysit that
past pun and what else just right here
to secure this pawn offer a queen trade
or just take this pawn next it's looking
to stay Gordon let's open up this file
okay now we have another pawn that's
rolling with check down on time back to
tournament 42 excuse me 42 thirty nine
thirty tans now let's do something else
let's try a gambit let's try a gambit
okay they're not going for that so what
do we have an exchange caro-kann by
transposition a very slight one I have
my Bishop exactly where I want it
outside this pawn chain and I want to
finish up my development how have the
h-file if they take my bishop I might
want to consider queenside castle since
my rook is already playing could just
block here and I want to jump my knight
in here maybe take if Knight here let's
have my King defend this pawn so my
knight is free to move let me go for a
queen trade not so fast though not so
fast let's make sure this tricky Knight
is out of my territory it's not leaving
so I'm up a pond now and I just want to
simplify stuff my rook is still very
active I'm on this half open file clean
trade no I didn't want to do that okay
let's do this pawn push maybe I have
this defendant it's a little bit scary
but I have it defended I keep pushing
the pawn and right let's take good take
here with double check and it might lead
to mate if rook takes rook I take here
and then made on c1 shack and then this
is gonna be a mating - no matter what
it's double check the King has to do
something one of these two that's me
back to terminate fifty six fifty three
forty two forty thirty eight
Ian Ian SIA okay
French potentially okay okay now there
LightSquared Bishop is going to have
some problems let me support my Center
and I'm looking for Queen e2 h4 dark
square bishop to just baby-step it here
oh I could have played my knight right
there okay well this is I think this is
still fine let me kick this night off
that square and I don't want that pawn
to go any further I could still do this
but I'm not going to this bishops close
to being crunched g5 dark squares are
weakened and what else that pond and ie
still secure could jump in here next and
I'll pawn push
I don't know how good this is but
capture like this do pawn push it's
gonna be met with b4 let me just make
sure that night is out of there and get
my F pawn working even if I have to
sacrifice it okay now he's going and
then I want to get at f7 f7 is where I
want to be okay I'm threatening Bishop
takes Bishop they're also pretty pretty
much down on time ro takes f7 take here
cuz now the pawn is pinned push here now
this pawn is pin two pins working I'm
working on f7 let's take with check mmm
let's back up I'm on this pond twice
there's a battery where's the mate
they're down on time 72 70 69 68 Oh
we're not even halfway they're not even
halfway there let's try this I'm not
sure what it's going to lead to but
let's give it a shot and take you can
get this working it's a different
structure for sure probably a bad
structure but let's let's see if I could
get my knight now on f4 my bishop would
probably have the door slammed in its
face soon just like that now I'm looking
at that f4 square what is my light
square bishop going to do what is he
going to do
can I sacrifice somehow Wow
Wow okay I don't know how to make
further progress because my um my bishop
is so stupid
let's double up here okay now let's take
and pinpoint this pond so Bishop a6
the knight has a pivot Square here let's
get him out of there this pawn is now
dropping I missed that
should I be afraid ah well the knight
could just reach recapture
ah oh man oh that's a nice home now oh
I'm winning everything that Knight is in
a perfect spot okay and I surprisingly
have fantastic coordination and this is
leading to main Wow
I know that's not me there is it oh the
King could go there let's try this again
I thought that was me let's try this
let's try it now where is the main where
is that me
okay now I'm threatening just take the
pawn seven point three seconds does that
mean that's me Wow haha my bishop was so
stupid ninety eighty six seventy two
seventy well we're more than halfway
there for four fourteen minutes fourteen
minutes remaining
okay all right Queens gambit oh my
goodness
stay away from that who knows what that
was or what it almost was Oh a F G a F G
who's gonna notice it in the chat first
who's gonna be the first to type it a F
G yes
I can't even I'm looking at the corner
of my eye somebody's saying that bunch
of people are saying it that's if you
did not know it's the adobe flash gambit
the most feared type of gambit on chess
cube
okay let's get at age seven maybe the
night is going to want to do something
tricky after he moves I play here is
you're gonna want to hit me with a fork
might be appealing age seven h7 boom 110
106 83 13 minutes remaining
oh they beat me would beat me to the
punch there okay I had to adjust my
mouse pad there for a second he was
getting out of hand out of hand
get back to home square they're back
back to home oh that's a free pun and
he's not he could always just take out
that bishop but maybe I like my knight
way too much and now this pawn is down
you know this pawn is down and my
LightSquared bishop is the one I need to
get working my night is now excited
about being firmly secured on this
square and now that is officially a fork
a fork this is trouble all the squares
covered back to tournament 130 106 90 83
future GM future GM mainline Cairo and
I'm gonna play age six okay let's do
this let's leave out the h5 let's try
this line queenside castle Knight e4 and
get g4 working and yep g4 working this
was played recently I believe okay so
the coins are gonna come off and now
let's try this ending now I'm really
wishing I had my pawn here okay now
these pawns are fixed on a dark square
and this is not really how
to be playing to try that we have to
sneak my king over I want to get him on
e - I'm working myself into a pin but I
can quickly get out of it and I want to
get my majority going hanging on though
okay I'm a okay King position I was
wanting to get this c4 move in quickly
my King has to babysit upon for right
now and I want to play c4 let's give it
checked am i okay with the rook trade oh
let's try it as king upon ending
am i okay how do I take you force the
situation let's force that situation do
I win this King and pawn ending let's
give it a shot three versus two I want
to keep this sitting I don't want to
allow them to have a an outside past
part I do not know who's gonna win this
stay tuned stay tuned okay hang on I
think because this pond has such depth
that I'm gonna end up winning because he
has to go after this pawn I think I
think it was important to maybe I think
this was that can't move now he just
keeps going and I get this pond and I'm
very quick to get this guy get out of
the way and well there's no time
150 150 126 Robbie Robbie Robbie the
robot is flying Robbie the flying robot
launching these age ponds at me like a
maniac
he's coming at me like a maniac Wow
I realized I was on that pond twice now
there's some crazy pins that night that
pond could be taken yes he can
let's drop back for a second that rook
is so crazy look at them could that
crazy rook I think I want to do this cut
that off for a second there's the main
there any mates okay can I get this
prawn before there's a crazy uh oh my
goodness this is so scared this is so
scary I got to watch out for this square
and so much more
oh man that nights gonna move what's the
count
what's the material count here okay I
mean definitely in a pin let's get out
of it if I can okay I don't know if my
opponent should have been going for that
but okay this seems sufficient this
seems very very good for my opponent can
I get my pawns working somehow I wanna
hang on to him okay I have to end up
giving up my rook for these guys they
are very fast actually I could do this
it's some type of an interference can I
get a queen I'm getting a queen but this
is still a lot of work two queens are on
the scene but there's no time I get this
oh my goodness they're down in time I
got so lucky as usual
I'm in second I'm in second right now
how much time is left oh my goodness oh
man let's try this Wow where did my time
go
somebody tell me please where did that
time go tricky Fork tricky Fork
okay that night is still pinned let's
take him out and I don't want to take I
want to push my opponent around a little
bit get rid of that bishop let me do
this actually that night is way short on
squares and I'm gonna pin it and win it
could have gone here this is a pin in
what no it's not a pin in a win I lied
it takes pawn might be available I don't
know what I'm doing oh I should probably
attack that night let's get out of here
attack this night okay are they gonna
push really let's get back here it's a
good spot I'm on the bishop was I'm the
bishop earlier
now the knight it know he has to go here
let's open this up all right I got half
to break this down break down those
pawns okay now this is I'm gonna be up
upon there's a disconnect between the
rooks
their bishop is very very active that
was a lucky lucky move right there that
I had a lucky little tactic okay King
position King position and working
position 12 seconds no okay right here
give a check get my king doing something
more get my King doing something more
now I could jump in here grab this pond
are they gonna take King up March these
ponds it's a nut stalemate they still in
the pond move they reside back to
tournament I don't know how much time I
had I don't think I had very much
1.2 or something excuse me sorry about
that sniffle I'm still in second still
in second where are the quick wins
there's not a single quick win around
can I get one though threatening maybe
take on this square pin this night first
let's see if I could induce some
weaknesses okay this is a soft point
stop the knight from playing here I want
to kick the night around are they going
to give up their central point I think
everything collapses if they do that
tonight is dead oh he has to go to the
corner I'm gonna take here I'm gonna
take on this square bunch now when the
knight moves I get here or here with
check this is gonna lead to mate very
soon very very soon bishop in and then
rook takes pawn as a threat may have one
threat
[Music]
probably some eight I'm just missing it
take with the pun and then still made IQ
mating ideas rook here look here rook
takes with Queen h2 stuff it's just um
no I don't know what I'm spending too
much time oh no oh no what'd I just do
ah I messed up with pre moves or
something
ah okay I think it should still be okay
oh no Queen takes pawn here connector
passed pawns Knight right here get these
pawns moving I'm in check
I need my rooks coordinated yeah let me
get my rigs coordinated well they only
have four seconds get behind these past
pawns and finally get pushing ah that
was a terrible pre mover something to
3210 204 146 3 minutes 50 seconds no no
fries no no fries always gives me a
difficult time here alright let's open
this position up otherwise I'm not okay
this Knight has to now find a new home I
have a space advantage and a lead in
development I want to get a 5 in soon
you know I could give it support let's
just open this up right now
I'm on the rook I should've taken with
the Queen rook up defends that point
though ok pawn takes discovered check
not long off okay Bishop takes pawn if
Queen takes pawn I think it might still
work the King has to sneak out here
that's borderline crazy but it might be
needed what else are they considering
just hit Queen takes pawn Bishop takes
pawn okay I'm just getting this there is
some check here King has to run away to
act in pieces tack those pin pieces
now I'll take and they are now stripped
of all defenders here probably no matter
what if King here and takes the be
something like Queen g5 get my rook over
okay there's a check
Brooke over Queen g7 is not long off 14
seconds 13 seconds 12 11 10 do don't let
my lip don't whenever you do this game
is just not gonna finish it's gonna be a
time thing let me just have a flight
square just in case just in case in no
time back determine tooth of 270 Wow Wow
booger cap gotta play against booger cat
oho quick resign here hang on hang on
250 250 270 250 I taught this in Flast
Flacco Flacco I thought I was gonna be
playing as Flacco here this game I don't
know if it will finish let's go after
this guy oh ok hang on
a little scary a little scary night
jumping in here tonight jumping here
could have considered taking I probably
should have done that my knight wants to
do something else he's really good there
this rook over here 57 seconds that's a
free bishop or they can resign oh
they're just trying to farm at me do
they think the games not going to finish
it might not this pawn rolling it's a
free free piece can I get this 43
seconds oh hang on it's a check where
the mates my bishop is stupid Oh
am i doing one and then two just will
they're gonna let the clock tick now
they did in fact determine 270 have a
lead
I've only 270 although I'm winning on
the tiebreak s-- oh come on just finish
just finish just finish call it blow the
whistle on this tournament oh come on
did I get it tonight get it did I get it
oh man come on assign those Cubans mate
in one sign those cubits they're
assigned what did I get what did I get
what did I get did that guy get
something second place
oh he must have come right back oh he
came right back he must have got the W
once he got the W oh I had a buzzer
beater but he had a better buzzer beater
man 292 7276
236 all right